hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round five of the
first day of the blitz in paris after
three days wesley so is leading uh the
tournament but now we still have two
more days of blitz and then we'll see
what happens so here
uh etienne bacro left the tournament he
was a wild card for the rapid section of
the tournament and now vladimir kromnic
is the wild card for the blitz section
of the tournament
and uh it's always nice when uh a
retired player comes back to play some
chess and here he faces alireza farouja
so a 45 year old kramnik versus 18 year
old alireza let's see uh how it goes and
it's uh it's really
an amazing game especially because it's
a blitz game uh it's just uh
uh very very complicated and very very
subtle moves are are um you know
being played here so without further ado
let's check it out kramnik with the
white pieces
opens with e4 we have c5 furuta goes for
the
sicilian defense we have knight to f3 d6
uh
and now d4 striking in the center we
have c captures knight captures and
now knight to f6 attacking this e4 pawn
knight to c3 defending and a6 going for
the neither
variation of the sicilian defense with a
for now
preventing b5 anytime soon from black
and the g6 preparing to fianchetto not
the king but
the dark square bishop with bishop to e2
and the bishop to g7 so this has all
been played many times
uh nothing nothing new here we have
castles
and uh alireza also castles with bishop
to e3
and now knights to c6 so both players
just nicely
uh developing pieces queen d2 developing
the queen connecting rooks
and bishop to d7 now with rook
after d1 and now rook the c8 we have f3
now strengthening this e4 pawn
and rook to e8 and here we have bishop
to f1
uh this position has been reached and
it's been reached in 2009 in amber
tournament
and in a blindfold game uh between
gatakomsky and vasily manchuk
the game ended in a draw but this game
might not
because in this game knight the e5 was
played and this is now a new move
in the position in the game that i
mentioned kamsky versus evan chook
uh queen to c7 was played but here
knight to e5 is a new move so already
as of move 13 we have a completely new
game
so let's see uh how kramnik deals with
this he starts with b3
later on he wants to move this knight
then maybe c4
and star start pushing some points on
the queen side we have queen to a5
now the c3 square has been weakened and
now there's a double attack on the
knight here and
vladimir just moves the knight and
offers a trade of queens
so queen captures alireza obliges we
have bishop captures on d2 and
now d5 striking in the center going for
some
uh some more trades with e captures
knight captures and then now
c4 so now kramnik gets the uh
push his pawn all the way to c4 and
later on he wants to push pawns even
further maybe b4 c5
and so on uh and here uh the c4
is kind of a deadly there but it's not
maybe the kind of uh
move you will play against the former
world champion here knight captures on
c4
is might be what alireza would play
against anyone else but here he
maybe decided that maybe it would be too
tricky to try this against uh
against vladimir kramnik because you
really get a lot for this piece you get
one pawn and then after captures you get
the second pawn
and now there's a double attack on the
knight here so you're threatening to win
a piece
uh and also there is an attack on the
third pawn so white cannot defend
everything white has to move the bishop
so the rook defends the knight here
and then we just grab the third pawn and
now for the price of one piece
we grabbed three pawns so we now have
six pawns our opponent has three
and we have two connected pass pawns on
the queen side so that's uh
that's compensation in itself uh but he
decides against that he goes back knight
to f6
and now comes a5 grabbing more space
here
and uh leaving alireza with the weak b7
backward spawn
so here we have knight to d3 uh and
now comes bishop to c3 saying okay you
move this knight
this knight is too powerful here knights
to c5 and
now comes b4 you don't want this b3 pawn
to remain a target here so b4
uh knight to a4 and here c5 and here
kramnik really expanded well on the
queen side uh but
there's a problem here uh now uh he
weakened the d5 square and
of course alireza goes after that square
so knight to d5 with
a double attack on the bishop here
bishop has to move and now
knight to b2 attacking the rook and once
again shifting the knight towards d3
so we have rook d to b1 attacking the
knight
and now not knight d3 but knight to c4
as the bishop here is now undefended
so bishop has to move and here uh
if you move the bishop you can move the
bishop of course for example bishop to
a1 and then we're going to play knight c
to e3
and it's a really uh ugly position for
for white to play this bishop still
slicing all the way here the knights
really controlling all of the squares
here
uh the other bishop is coming to at the
f5 at some point we're going to pressure
the other rook as well and it's going to
be
impossible to hold this so instead after
knight to c4
uh kramnik defends the bishop with rook
to a2 makes sense you kind of want to
get rid of at least one of those knights
and you want to get your rook away from
this square here
but now the position is really really
bad for for kramnik so feel free to
pause the video
and try to find the uh the absolute best
move for black here while i
well i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
figuring out that it is able it is
possible for whites to
to grab a pawn here and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it is uh e5 and e5 is just the beautiful
because the knight has to go to b3 and
this rook will no longer be defending
the spawn
uh you of course can't go here because
then we no longer defend the bishop we
can just pick up the piece here
so knight to b3 was played and now of
course we want to eliminate this bishop
and pick up the b4 pawn but first
bishop to f5 let's utilize the other
bishop as well now the rook and b1 is
under attack you can't go to b2
and now uh because if you just capture
then knight will capture and then this
rook defends the b4 pawn you want to get
the rook away from the b4 pawn
uh rook to d1 and now just knight
captures on d2 and on the next move
we're going to capture the b4 pawn
so rook a captures on d2 we have knight
captures on b4 and now
knight to g3 so here kramnik is down
upon
and he's gonna have to work really
really hard not not to lose this so
bishop to e6
uh and now comes rook to b1
and here uh the maybe better than rook
to b1
uh was this knight the e4 threatening
the fork here with knight to d6
uh and it's uh well it's a it's a very
nice uh idea
uh here here uh a lot of moves are
possible black will probably play
uh something like bishop captures on b3
but you don't have to go for bishop
captures on b3 right away you can go
knight to c6 first
and uh still it's gonna be it's going to
be very tricky if knight to c1 if white
doesn't want to lose a piece here
uh then you can play rook to b8 for
example defended this spawn
and now uh well you you won't have all
that many weaknesses here along the b
file and this will not be as potent so
it's definitely one of the possibilities
so even though black would be better
here
maybe this knight the e4 idea was uh
was possible because if you go for this
and then black just captures some b3 you
can play rook to b1 and now you have a
double attack here and you
you will you know uh black will of
course be better in all of these lines
but
maybe maybe it was better than what
happened in the game uh in the game
kramnik played rook to b1
and now uh alireza just started
expanding here with f5
we have knight to c1 now attacking the
knight here but now just
bishop to h6 and this is another
beautiful move
saying okay we're not going to move this
to lose the b7 pawn let's
throw this move in and now you have to
move it uh so here we have rook to d6
uh but now bishop to e3 check the c5
pawn is now free for grabs
we have king to h1 and now bishop
captures on c5 defends the knight
attacks the rook and now
alireza is up two pawns so here kramnik
has to resort to to what's left
rook captures on e6 was played rook
captures him bishop to c4 now
attacking the rook so king has to defend
king to f7
and now knight c to e2 uh so what do you
play here
we have bishop back to e7 balireza
attacking the bishop here and now
bishop captures an e6 with king captures
and h3
so here kramnik was able to win back his
exchange but he's still down two pawns
so here
rook to c2 and nothing like rook on the
seventh rank
uh okay this is the second rank but you
know to the other player it's the
seventh rank
so here we have rook to e1 but now king
to f7
and this is just a really really ugly
position uh we have knight to c1
trying to re-maneuver the knight back
into the game but now bishop to h4 and
this is unplayable
uh we have knight c back to e2 but now
f4 uh we have
rook to b1 now saying okay maybe we can
trade pieces but here
alireza just played bishop captures on
g3 and he was in this position on move
42
that uh vladimir kramnik resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here
so it's a really incredible game like i
said especially because it's a blitz
game it had
so many uh so many possibilities so many
secrets and hidden options
uh that uh you know it's really really
impressive
how well it is i was able to to take
vladimir down like that
so here you resign because if you just
trade here for example rook captures on
b4 we play rook captures on e2
and uh well you just down a piece and on
the other hand if you
if you just pick up the the bishop here
knight captures on b3
then f captures on b3 and we're again up
a piece because if white captures then
rook to c1 is checkmate so really really
awesome stuff
so after a bishop captures on g3 kramnik
resigned and
a brilliant brilliant victory for
alireza with the black pieces against uh
against the vladimir comics so
incredibly impressive stuff
so yeah uh there are many many games
being played so uh you know if don't be
don't be shy of using the hashtag
suggestion so i can you know
find more games for for you guys to
enjoy i'm going through them
myself of course but there are many
games being played so if you have a
favorite feel free to use hashtag
suggestion
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank rajesh
adam shire amirmaron uh zachary harmon
and abdul aziz abdulgani for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon at
continuing the coverage of this very
nice event
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day